le monde entier
[Musique]
donne-moi tes lèvres
et je ferai le reste
City
[Musique]
non plus non plus gave
ce que le fait
faire partie
[Musique]
c'est pas bien
38000 euros je crois c'est
mon cartable et je le retrouvais avec
plein de colle dedans c'est c'était
horrible pour moi et le pire c'est que
je savais par qui mais j'ai jamais osé
le dire et un jour j'ai reçu un message
sur Facebook il y a pas si longtemps on
dit ouais tu étais un copain de mon père
je voulais te dire qu'il était décédé et
tout et c'est un des deux qui m'avait
fait ça ce monsieur a sûrement dit plus
tard qu'il était un copain à moi
puisqu'il me connaissent à l'école
tu cours tu tournes tu sautes je te dis
pas la hauteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous
qui va prendre une photo il y en a
dépêche qui va pas être photo